[Musique]
profite d'une journée mondiale de l'eau
pour publier lancer un avis prévenir
qu'il y a une crise mondiale de l'eau
qui se qui se dessine à l'horizon on
dirait pas quand on voit toutes ces taux
dans les images que vous nous montrez là
mais ça c'est les endroits je dirais
peut-être un peu plus riche qui ont les
moyens de se donner de l'eau de l'EN
chercher si on en a pas mais c'est
difficile à bien bien plus d'endroit que
ça faut avoir une vision globale c'est
ce qui ressort dans ce nouveau rapport
qui a été publié aujourd'hui on insiste
beaucoup sur la coopération mondiale qui
est nécessaire en ce moment et pour les
prochaines années ce qui est particulier
c'est que cette conférence de l'ONU sur
l'eau c'est la première en près de 50
ans d'ailleurs les experts le disent on
parle beaucoup de changements
climatiques mais on parle pas assez de
la crise de l'eau alors il y a un
rapport qui a été publié je vous ressors
les grandes lignes ce matin entre autres
on dit justement l'eau doit être géré
comme un bien commun et non une
marchandise alors ça c'est vraiment
l'idée générale qui revient beaucoup
maintenant on consomme de plus en plus
d'eau c'est certain que la population
mondiale augmente également mais on dit
depuis 40 ans la demande en eau a
augmenté d'un pour cent par année et
cette tendance va se poursuivre jusqu'en
2050 ça c'est à l'échelle mondiale mais
lorsqu'on regarde dans les zones
urbaines et populations urbaines
augmentent et on dit que d'ici 2050 donc
en moins de 30 ans la demande en eau
dans les villes va augmenter de 80%
imaginez-vous alors le nombre de
personnes en zone urbaine qui va manquer
d'eau va augmenter de 50%. qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour tenter de pallier ce
déséquilibre mais on va chercher de
l'eau dans les zones agricoles et là on
crée qui demande d'eau dans les ondes
agricoles d'ailleurs il y a des ondes de
sécheresse de plus en plus avec les
conditions extrêmes sur la planète on le
voit mais selon ce rapport il y a 10% de
la planète de la population planétaire
qui souffre de stress hydrique ce que ça
veut dire c'est que la demande est plus
grande que l'offre disponible alors on
manque d'eau pour subvenir à ses besoins
10% de la population planète Terre donc
mais on dit qu'il y a un une personne
sur deux dans le monde qui a ressenti ce
stress hydrique au moins une fois dans
l'année alors un peu partout sur la
planète là ça se ressent c'est tout qui
se fait de plus en plus rare évidemment
il y a aussi l'enjeu du traitement des
eaux de l'accès à l'eau potable de façon
sécuritaire et ça c'est vraiment
difficile pour les pays en développement
il y a 26 % de la population mondiale ça
c'est à peu près 2 milliards de
personnes qui n'ont pas accès à un
système sécuritaire pour avoir accès à
l'eau potable il y a même 80% des eaux
usés sur la planète qui ne sont pas
traitées et ça c'est problématique ça
cause des maladies et ça participe au
service vicieux de la pauvreté justement
ces eaux usées le problème majeur c'est
que ça coûte cher alors c'est pour ça
qu'on parle d'un bien commun on doit
financer globalement ces traitements des
eaux usées parce qu'au final c'est toute
la planète qui est top en terminant un
petit mot sur le Canada ici on est bien
chanceux au pays on a 20% des réserves
d'eau douce sur la planète imaginez-vous
ça veut pas dire qu'on est à l'abri de
cette crise de l'eau il y a encore 30
premières nations qui n'ont pas accès à
l'eau potable dans le pays même d'autres
petites communités rurales et également
des problèmes de contamination avec les
engrais agricoles également l'extraction
de sa lumineux qui peut contaminer
notre eau potable alors c'est vraiment
des enjeux auxquels on fait aussi face
au pays et on profite de la Journée
mondiale de l'eau pour en parler
évidemment un choc parce que les
Canadiens on est tellement nombreux à
vivre près de lourds garder Montréal
Québec trois lumières il y a d'autres
villes également qui sont établies sur
les cours d'eau tellement une richesse
et oui tout à fait on était étonné que
certaines personnes et certains pays en
manque merci
22 mars c'est la journée mondiale de
l'eau c'est une crise de l'eau à
l'échelle planétaire qui se profile à
l'horizon pour moi qu'il a fait pour
nous qu'il affirmons c'est un nouveau
rapport de l'UNESCO là-dessus dans le
cadre d'une conférence de l'ONU sur
l'autre tout ça va débuter dans quelques
minutes à New York c'est la première de
cette ampleur là depuis 46 ans pourtant
la situation est loin d'être rose dans
le secteur de l'eau notre journaliste
spécialisé en environnement et si elle
Leblanc est avec tout pour nous parler
justement de cette situation bonjour
merci d'être venu nous retrouver
corrigez-moi si j'entends vraiment que
je me trompe et vous comprenez ma
question on a l'impression parce qu'on
vit sur tout près d'un fleuve on vit
tout près des lacs nos villes sont
tellement au Canada en Amérique du Nord
près des cours d'eau sur des raisons
évidentes que nous on n'a pas de
problème d'eau le Canada de fait
Marc-André le cinquième des réserves
d'eau potable au monde d'autres de ce
monde donc on a beaucoup d'eau au Canada
au Québec c'est 3% des réserves
mondiales c'est pour rien quand même
donc il y a beaucoup d'eau sur notre
territoire des lacs des rivières le
fleuve Saint Roch alors vous l'avez dit
donc on a l'impression que cette
ressource ici elle est inépuisable or
c'est pas du tout le cas vous savez on
est les plus grands consommateurs d'eau
potable au monde ou dans les plus grands
on consomme en moyenne au Canada 329
litres d'eau par jour par personne au
Québec c'est encore pire 400 litres
d'eau par jour par personne qu'on
consomme au Québec alors que la moyenne
mondiale c'est à peu près 130 litres par
jour donc on est des très très grands
consommateurs d'eau ça c'est une chose
et d'autre part on se rend compte que il
y a de plus en plus de conflits pour
l'usage des eaux au Canada parce que
tout le monde veut de l'eau les
agriculteurs veulent de l'eau les villes
pour se développer veulent de l'eau les
industries veulent de l'eau donc dans
les zones d'enseignement peuplées
l'usage de l'eau et est en conflit et
donc on a une abondance générale on
pourrait dire mais la rareté elle est
très locale il y a des problèmes et
notamment vous en parlerons aux
agriculteurs dans l'Ouest là en 2021 ils
ont connu très très grande très très
grande sécheresse et ça va pas
s'améliorer parce que en raison des
changements climatiques entre autres il
y a de moins en moins de neige dans les
Rocheuses et c'est la principale source
d'eau pour les prairies notamment la
grande rivière Saskatchewan qui abreuve
des millions de personnes dans l'ouest
du pays je regarde les images et les
conditions de ski ailleurs dans le monde
vous avez vu l'Europe de course on
descend dans les slalom c'est très beau
de chaque côté on peut pas se mettre en
scandale à des milliers de mètres
d'altitude vous venez de parler le
défait de réchauffement avec vraiment de
toute cette question des gaz et
effectivement du GIEC une synthèse
également et puis c'est un influence sur
l'eau évidemment tout ça c'est lié en
fait vous disiez ce grand rapport de
l'UNESCO aussi là donc qui qui nous
rappelle que des gens qui n'ont pas
accès à l'eau des milliards de personnes
qui n'ont pas accès à l'eau et la
demande de l'eau va doubler dans les
prochaines années et elle elle augmente
de 1% par année depuis 40 ans on veut
toujours plus d'eau et rapport du GIEC
nous rappelait cette semaine que ça va
pas s'améliorer parce que les cycles
hydro climatiques les extrêmes les
inondations les sécheresses vont se
empirer dans l'avenir notamment dans les
zones plus vulnérables où ils ont pas
les infrastructures pour faire face à
ces extrêmes climatiques notamment en
Afrique en Asie du Sud-Est en Amérique
latine etc est-ce que le GX se prononce
sur l'accès à l'eau bien sûr la question
de l'eau c'est fondamentale c'est la
ressource la plus importante de la
planète donc oui le GIEC parle de l'eau
sur les 20 000 pages qu'il y a eu dans
les six rapports qui ont été publiés
depuis six ans il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de données scientifiques sur l'eau et
dans le rapport qui a été publié lundi
qui est un une grande synthèse
formidable synthèse cela dit 37 pages
bien tassées qui nous qui nous donne les
grands défis climatiques dont celui de
l'accès à l'eau qui sera de plus en plus
grand comme défi vous savez juste le
fait que vous disiez 37 pages quand on
part de 20 000 à 37 déjà ça nous donne
ça va intéresser davantage le
consommateur les effets pour ça c'est
fait pour le lire et moi je l'ai lu je
vous le dis ça se lit très bien et on
espère qu'il va se retrouver sur les
bureaux des responsables politiques
parce que toute l'information est là bon
ben tant mieux merci beaucoup Étienne
d'être
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]